[Music]
is there really such a thing as happily
ever after in the school for good and
evil Sophie and Agatha learn that there
is a fine line between wicked witch and
fairy princess spoilers ahead
like many young girls Sophie dreams of
being the princess of her very own fairy
tale she longs to escape her dull life
in the village of Gabaldon and become
the extraordinary person she was always
meant to be after Sophie makes a wish
that takes her in Agatha to the school
for good and evil it seems that all of
her dreams are about to come true what
she discovers is that being in a true
fairy tale world is nothing like what
she had hoped for although Sophie
believes that her pretty hair and her
affinity for nice things make her the
perfect candidate for the school of good
her actions speak otherwise she breaks
her promise to Agatha not to leave
Gabaldon she's dishonest with the boy
she insists is her true love and she
completely disregards Agatha's feelings
about wanting to return home though she
claims to be good time and time again
Sophie proves that the only person she
cares about is herself an innately evil
trait it isn't until the end of the
school for good and evil that Sophie
realizes the destruction that her
choices have wrought her need to feel
special has caused pain to everyone
around her and allowed her to be easily
manipulated by Rafal however she finally
comes to understand that being special
means nothing if it means losing the
ones you care about casting her selfish
wants aside selfie makes the ultimate
sacrifice to save her best friend's life
even if it means losing her own in the
end Sophia returns to Gabaldon a little
bit humbler and a little bit wiser
for the majority of her life Agatha has
been an outcast thanks to her mother's
affinity for brewing potions that don't
actually work the villagers of Gabaldon
call Agatha a witch and Bully her
incessantly it doesn't help that she
wears drab clothes and doesn't follow
societal Norms her only comfort has been
her best friend Sophie who has always
had her back and shown her kindness but
when Sophie says that she is leaving
Gabaldon forever Agatha fears being
alone once more desperate to hold on to
her only friend Agatha travels with
Sophie to the land of fairy tales and
the school for good and evil much to her
shock Agatha has been placed in the good
school instead of Sophie who somehow
ended up on the evil side oh it must be
in Hell being forced to wear fancy ball
gowns and act pretty and polite is not
Agatha's idea of paradise and all she
wants is to find Sophie so they can both
go home yet as Sophie succumbs to the
evil inside her Agatha knows that her
friend has to be saved and she's the
only one who can do it after years of
Sophie coming to Agatha's rescue now
it's Agatha's turn to rescue Sophie all
Agatha has ever wanted was an ordinary
life but her ability to empathize with
others and her willingness to stand
against depression makes her an
extraordinary person in the end Agatha
finds the hero within herself to help
her friend and save the whole school she
also learns to embrace her uniqueness
rather than to be ashamed of it
from the moment Agatha arrives at the
good school it's clear that things are
not what they seem she encounters
Angelic fairies with razor sharp teeth
and hostile dispositions a beauty class
that fails students for not smiling
prettily enough and mean girl princesses
who would put Regina George to shame it
quickly becomes apparent that the school
of good is not so much interested in
being good but in appearing good a
conversation between Dean dovey of the
good side and Dean leso of the evil side
reveals that even they have their
suspicions of things not being quite
right at the school though it's stated
that the school Master doesn't make
mistakes it's also inferred that
questioning him can lead to terrible
consequences luckily Agatha isn't afraid
to stand up and fight against the
injustices she Witnesses within the
school if there's one thing that the
school for good and evil tries to get
across it's that Authority should be
questioned and if need be challenged
even the most well-meaning authority
figures are not invaluable and in the
case of the school for good and evil
many of them can be hiding secret
corruption as Agatha and the other
students learn things won't change
unless someone steps forward to change
them
when Sophie accepts her role as a witch
she becomes the queen bee at the evil
School trading her long locks and fancy
gowns for a stylish Bob and fashionable
black attire Sophie appears to be in her
element even Tedros the handsome and
popular Prince from the good school
can't seem to resist her charms even
with her rise in social status and
Newfound confidence Sophie is still
determined to prove that she belongs in
the good school yet Ezra Fall's
influence keeps its hold on her she
finally gives in to her darkest impulses
and he gives Sophie with the power of
forbidden blood magic that's when
Sophie's transformation from light to
dark begins to show in physical and
terrifying ways starting with a dark
mole on her cheek Sophie's good looks
begin to change into that of a fairy
tale hag she gets a long hooked nose
deep wrinkles and thin white hair
instead of being horrified by the change
Sophie Embraces it as her magical power
grows but it's more than just rafal's
dark power that initiated the
transformation as Sophie's actions
become increasingly evil the darkness of
her heart manifests in grotesque ways
where once she was young and beautiful
like a princess her looks changed to
mirror what she has become come on the
inside a wicked witch
in the movies prologue we learned that
brothers rhiann and Rafal are
responsible for maintaining the balance
of Good and Evil but if good always wins
over evil can there really be a balance
this is explained in the film's third
act when the evil reval reveals that he
killed his brother riyan thus tipping
the balance in Evil's favor disguising
himself as the good school's Master
Rafal was able to take over without
anyone ever noticing that anything was
amiss so why did no one ever question
why good always has the upper hand after
all these years as the epitome of evil
Rafal is a master of deception and
manipulation on top of that teachers and
students alike have become complacent
and assume that good will always triumph
over evil it's this hubris that makes it
so easy for a fall to fool everyone but
good has won for 200 years
have they now
Story by story I have corrupted them
meanwhile the school of good is happy to
feed their egos rather than believe that
something is wrong as a result they lose
their ability to see beyond their
shallow desires which makes it easy for
them to become weak and for a fall to
enact his scheme luckily Agatha and
Sophie arrive at the school just in time
to upend the status quo and restore the
balance once more
fairy tales have always been designed to
Thrill young children as well as
entertain them most importantly they're
meant to teach morals and prove that
being good will always win the day
however real life isn't so simple and
the school for good and evil
demonstrates that even in the land of
fairy tales good and evil are not always
what they appear to be throughout the
movie we see villains dressed in black
and heroes dressed in bright Pleasant
colors in the movie's Climax and intense
battle breaks out between the evil
students and the good Sophie uses her
magic to transform the evil students
clothing into white and the good
students black in a symbolic gesture
that suggests their roles have changed
as the heroes and villains Clash it
becomes almost impossible to tell who is
who earlier in the movie when Dean dovey
asked Agatha if she believes that Sophie
is truly good Agatha has a very
perceptive answer I don't believe that
anyone is truly good or truly evil
because people are complicated in
stating one of the biggest themes of the
school for good and evil Agatha hits the
nail right on the head at the movie's
conclusion this Revelation suggests a
big change for the future of the school
for good and evil
anyone who survived High School knows
how harmful labels can be whether it's
nerd jock Band Geek or something worse
these epithets are used either to
degrade or to elevate a person's status
they can also be used as a way for young
people to Define themselves on their way
to discovering their personal identities
which is an important stepping stone in
growing up now imagine what it would be
like to grow up with the idea of either
being good or evil pounded into your
brain what kind of damage would that
cause what would that do to your ego in
the school for good and evil Sophie's
motivation comes from her mother's dying
words that she is special and destined
for great things while this was meant to
give her daughter hope Sophie took the
words to heart she truly believes that
she was meant to become a princess like
in her favorite fairy tale when that
dream is destroyed she goes to extreme
links to gain the power that she
believes she deserves and has been
denied similarly the students at both
the good and evil schools are trained to
be the best heroes or villains they can
be many of them are placed at the school
based on their bloodlines such as Tedros
who is the son of King Arthur and Hester
the daughter of a hag because they have
been led to to believe that they are who
they are because of where they come from
they don't realize that they have a
choice it isn't until Agatha saves the
day that the students come together as
allies instead of enemies and are free
to decide for themselves who they want
to be
unfortunately fairy tales have skewed
many of our views on the definition of
true love in most stories it's presented
as romantic love however as we've come
to learn true love comes in many forms
and besides romance isn't everyone's cup
of tea when Sophie and Agatha go to the
Schoolmaster to try and straighten
things out the Schoolmaster offers them
a chance to prove once and for all that
Sophie belongs on the good side of
course the one sure way to tell for
certain if someone is on the side of
good is for them to have true love's
kiss Sophie believes this to be an easy
task as she already has her eye on the
handsome prince Tedros of course things
are a bit more complicated than that
besides the fact that Tedros is already
dating Beatrix from the good side it
turns out that the attraction between
Sophie and Tedros is just superficial in
the end true love's kiss comes in an
unexpected form as Sophie lies dying in
Agatha's arms they share our kiss it
isn't a romantic gesture but rather a
kiss from her best friend whom she
dearly loves the kiss brings Sophie back
to life and the two friends are reunited
once more
every fairy tale ends the same way they
lived happily ever after at least that's
what we've been led to believe but as a
story ever truly end after Sophie and
Agatha return to Gabaldon it seems
things are back to normal for the young
women however in the movie's final scene
we see the portal between Gabaldon and
the land of fairy tales open and an
arrow shoots through and strikes a tree
a dagger with the hilt in the shape of a
dragon follows splitting the arrow in
two according to the story in the arrow
belongs to Tedros who calls out for
Agatha's help I need you Agatha this
ending is likely setting up a potential
sequel to Netflix's the school for good
and evil if that's the case it would
probably follow the plot of the second
book in the series a world without
princes in the book Agatha and Sophie
returned to the school to find that the
girls and boys have been separated with
all the girls now on the good side and
all the boys on the evil side it's up to
Sophie and Agatha to figure out what's
gone wrong at the school and try to fix
it
[Music]